this is the daily climate show coming up
improved food security and crops
resilient to climate change new
legislation aims for a revolution in the
way we farm
the human cost of climate change how
should the world deal with the millions
made homeless by extreme weather every
year
and the activists forcing banks to
change their ways we hear from a winner
of the goldman environmental award
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show where we examine the huge challenge
facing humanity speak to those working
on adapting to that challenge and those
working on solutions
now new legislation is being introduced
by the government today which will
change the way we farm the aim to boost
food security and create crops more
resilient to disease and climate change
it's all about gene editing crops which
is subtly different from genetic
modification and its proponents say will
lead to fast advances in technology and
huge benefits to consumers so our
science and technology editor tom clark
has been looking at this in some detail
so tom first of all why is this
legislation being introduced now and
what will it mean for consumers
well the
purpose of this legislation is to make a
clear distinction between as you
mentioned the intro there gene editing
and genetic modification they're two
subtly different things but the
government hopes it's an important
difference and this legislation is
coming in now
because up until we left the eu we were
bound by the ruling of the european
court which decided that gene editing
and genetic modification were one in the
same thing now we've left the eu the
government wants to make a distinction
between the two in this piece of
legislation to say they are separate let
me explain what they are so gene
modification gm the one that we're used
to has been effectively banned in europe
it's very difficult to market a product
in europe since 2001 when they changed
the law and typically gene
is when you take a gene from one
organism and put it into another for
example genetically modified cotton to
be resistant to insects contains a gene
from a bacterium it's grown in the us
but not here in europe now genetic
editing allows you to go into
an organism and
edit literally like editing the text in
a book using bits of bacterial dna to
make some edits change you can shuffle
genes around repeat them delete them to
make changes you then take those genes
out and you're left with an organism
that contains its original dna the
argument from the biotech industry from
farmers and from scientists is that this
is no really no different to what you
could achieve using traditional breeding
therefore it should be different in law
we should be allowed to do it the
advantages they say is we can gene edit
crops as you say to make them more
nutritious to make them drought
resistant to make them better resistant
to high temperatures and give higher
yields which should be good for the
environment and for society
so that's what those backing the
proposals are saying but there has been
opposition as well hasn't there
absolutely i mean from the very
beginning
when
gene editing was has first emerged as a
technology about a decade ago
opponents of genetic modification of
waterfall it's just the same thing by a
different name you're still tinkering
with the natural genetic code of
organisms that is not a good thing that
the changes you make
could be the same as you could achieve
from traditional breeding crossing
plants together and let's face it that
is how most of our food crops have been
developed over uh the centuries um but
the um
it opens up the possibility opens the
door as opposed to expand that to
further and further and further changes
so there are those who are ideologically
opposed to it then there are others who
are saying
it's fine to look into these
technologies but to try and pretend that
they are the solution to our
environmental problems they are the
solution to the climate crisis for
example is also going too far shouldn't
the government focus more on
agricultural reform in the uk more
sustainable farming practices
land use reform
better crop varieties and they may have
a point we've certainly seen gm soybeans
and cotton have reduced pesticide and
herbicide inputs into central in south
america for example but it hasn't
stopped deforestation so is that tension
there i think the scientists have got a
lot to prove in terms of environmental
benefits but environmentalists are
challenged by this too how are we gonna
feed seven billion people with
increasingly plant-based diets if we
can't improve the plants that we've got
tom thanks very much indeed
let's get some of the day's other
climate news now and hundreds of
protesters have disrupted the total
energy's shareholders meeting in paris
this morning denouncing the energy
giant's continued presence in russia
greenpeace friends of the earth and
others said the french company should
pull all its assets from russia in
support of ukraine
tethal has said it will gradually
suspend its activities in russia and
will strictly comply with eu sanctions
wales has unveiled plans to make its
tourism industry more sustainable
following the increase in staycations
during the pandemic the 26 million pound
fund will aid climate-friendly
facilities such as carbon storage
protection for wildlife and rolling out
more electric vehicle charging points
almost half of britain's butterfly
species are at risk of extinction due to
climate change from a total of 62
species the charity butterfly
conservation found that four are now
extinct
24 are classed as threatened and five as
near threatened
but it's not all bad news two of the
species most threatened the large blue
and high brown fritillary are no longer
in the most at risk category after
successful targeted conservation
the atlantic hurricane season starts
next week and u.s forecasters say it'll
be the seventh consecutive year of
stronger than average storms
climate change is warming ocean
temperatures which in turn leads to more
destructive and damaging storms
according to climate scientists
more than 11 million people are driven
from their homes by storms every year
according to the internal displacement
monitoring centre now these pictures
show what happened when hurricane dorian
hit the bahamas in 2019 leaving
thousands homeless
and in india in 2020 millions of people
lost their homes when cyclone anfan hit
the bay of bengal
well the charity shelter box is drawing
attention to this issue today i'm joined
now by alice jefferson the head of
emergency response alice jefferson the
prediction then is that storms will
intensify so what's the potential human
cost of that
thank you yes
unfortunately shelterbox we know that
the climate crisis is one of the
greatest humanitarian threats currently
facing communities
around the world
we believe that more than 200 million
people will be uprooted over the next 20
years by storms intensified by climate
change and we provide emergency shelter
and other essential items after people
have lost their homes and we have built
witness and see first hand the
devastating effect that
storms and other related issues
intensified by climate change have on
both vulnerable people around the world
it does sound like a huge number of
people but some people will say how on
earth do you come to a figure like that
when although the scientists are saying
that storms will intensify we've got no
real idea of exactly which kind of
communities they'll hit do we
it's very difficult to say exactly who
will be hit and when but we are knowing
more and more um with more research and
there is more credibility and assurance
of the threats and the warnings so the
recent ipcc report has assessed how
severe the consequences of climate
change will be
and importantly the report is clear it's
thorough and it provides a really stark
warning and our estimate based on this
report and what you've mentioned from
the internal displacement monitoring
centre
really is a conservative estimate
and if we extrapolate those figures
further we know that millions of people
will need that support
and is there a certain amount that can
be done through adaptation to protect
communities to keep people in their
homes
i mean in recent years the number of
deaths globally caused by weather events
for example has come down that's
according to the world meteorological
organization
is there hope that adaptation may be
able to to protect people's homes
yes i think really importantly
adaptation plus anticipatory action in
the form of early warnings you know
we've seen um at shelterbox our recent
response to a severe storm in the
philippines um over sort of the december
period very high winds huge amounts of
rainfall that are comparable to super
typhoon haiyan back in 2013 which i
responded to
huge amounts of damage to people's homes
throughout both but the number of deaths
on the second more recent response was
was far lower than the first but the
human impact overall on livelihoods on
people's homes and shelters was was very
severe
so from a humanitarian perspective we
must anticipate and prepare for the
unavoidable consequences to make sure we
for example work with communities to
ensure we can support them to become
more resilient and many other
organizations do that very well
and we want to make sure that we've got
the right aid in the right place at the
right time to help people obviously
prevention is better than cure so we
need to make sure that we're taking
action now to reduce emissions but as an
organization that specializes in
emergency shelter after disaster
shelterbox must be prepared for
inevitable consequences for families who
are marginalized and most vulnerable to
this
well alice jefferson we appreciate you
coming on the show to tell us about your
work thanks very much indeed
thank
you now the 2022 winners of the goldman
environmental prize have been announced
today from activist lawyers all of the
recipients took on transnational
corporations or even their own
governments to force climate action
among them was julian vincent from
australia with just a second-hand laptop
and a spare room julian was able to
launch a campaign group that pushed all
four of australia's big banks to commit
to ending coal investments by 2030.
so i can be standing in front of the
bank with a megaphone at a protest
uh complaining or waxing lyrical about
their policies and then two days later
be discussing those very same policies
inside the bank with its staff and its
management but that wouldn't be possible
without the grassroots work and that's
the work that obviously um goldman
recognize it it's it's genuinely the
people power you know that phrase gets
thrown around quite a lot and can sound
a little bit trite but it works it's
worked time and again and we wouldn't
have had anywhere near the amount of
success we had
if it wasn't for
putting information in front of people
showing them what their financial
institutions are doing the custodians of
their money what they're doing and then
giving them the means and the
opportunity to
be an agent of change and use their own
money as a force for good
award winner julian vincent there that's
it for me thanks for watching i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you